he's calling in from the United States
open why don't you it is a big first day
at Pebble Beach and a man who has been
in this tournament many times a longtime
professional player on the tour and
broadcaster we got Peter Jacobsen
calling in from the US Open how you
doing Peter which I'm doing I'm doing
great it's chilly out here
first round excitement fans are piling
in and so many stories please to talk
about yeah so what's the first one that
leaves to mind for you for this first
one the leaves to mine is Brooks Capra
trying to win three in a row
nobody is nobody's won three US Opens in
a row for over a hundred years the next
story line would be Tiger Tiger trying
to win his second major of the year the
third would be Phil Mickelson trying to
complete the career grand slam he's
finished second sixth time in the US
Open and he has the best chance to win
the US Open right here in his beloved
couple Beach now normally I would say
how does this course set up for which
for which golfer does this court set up
best but you know Tiger once won there
by 15 so I guess that would answer the
question right Peter yeah yes which I
think when you start trying to compare
eras and LeBron to Kobe and Jack to
Tiger I think you have to look at the
dominating performances and there was no
more dominating performance in the US
Open than right here when Tiger won by
15 shots that's like winning the Indy
500 by 15 laps it just doesn't happen
and I think that's what sets a tiger
apart and why I think he has a great
chance this week he loves this place he
knows how to play here and even at 43
with all the back surgeries and knee
surgeries katie's he's used to one of
the favorite well while we're comparing
or at least discussing about comparing
eras who does Brooks koepka compared to
perhaps from when you played any is
there any comparison at all there's no
there's no comparison it's hard hard to
quantify guys like Brooks and Dustin
Johnson there's such great athletes you
when you watch him walk they've got that
swagger and the way they're built
they look like a c.b.c playing shooting
forward for the for the Golden State
Warriors or maybe defensive end for the
dog
they just they just look different than
your average golfer and the way they
play they've got power they've got
finesse
they've got touch around the greens it's
kind of the new the new prototypical
golfer so again when you were on the
tour of the PGA Tour
did no one get in the gym I mean were
there gyms
no rats no huh nobody no no nobody got
the gym back then it was all about just
keeping your flexibility and stretching
and trying to watch your diet nowadays
time even came along and easy nuts and
bolts for breakfast and he he's lifting
heavy weights before and after you guys
guys like glory and Jason Day and Justin
Thomas and jordan Spieth books just and
you guys lift unbelievable weight in the
gym like a real athlete golfers but my
era we're not we're not haffley's but
the kids today they are real athlete so
I guess the question I have for you then
is do you have a golfer or a player that
we're not talking about that you like
that you've seen that you you you think
the US Opens got a shot to see yeah yeah
I do I'm gonna go with Patrick Campbell
a Patrick who won two weeks ago in
Jack's tournament man even some great
players staring him down coming down the
stretch and he played precision golf
played looks like Nicklaus vid back in
the dangerous fairway in greens you got
to do that here at couple to win I I
think you're Dark Horse sleeper would be
Patrick Henley and the way the course
that you've seen it set up are we gonna
have any complaints people saying it's
too tough usually we see that from time
to time with the United States Open what
about this time at Pebble Peter of
course you know us professional golf you
know it's pro athletes gonna complain no
matter what and that's the one thing
that Nikolas always said when I played a
lot with Jack he said look I can count
on probably half the field to be out of
it before the first ball is struck
because everyone's because it complain
about fast greens hard greens long rough
tight fairways so yeah I think
you're gonna get your requisite amount
of complaining Peter Jacobsen here on
the Rich Eisen show what's your favorite
hole on the course number eight why they
get the best hole in golf par four plays
right along the edge of the Pacific
Ocean your second shot from the fairways
got to carry a big cavern a big Barranca
and the green is set right against the
hill really small little greens like
trying to hit to the hood of your car
and stop it it's uh it's my favorite
hole and in golf in all golf huh the
entirety of the golf world number eight
at Pebble you got it and then what what
what makes a United States Open more
difficult to when you think than any
other tournament
I think the USGA that's such a good job
they don't get enough credit for the
good stuff they do so the governing body
in the golf in the United States and and
I think what they try to do is identify
the best golfers by putting it putting
so much strain and pressure on them
patience putting the ball in play big
they reward precision as much as they go
distance and power and does not forget
accuracy counts in golf
and like it does in every other sport
and we should all kind of morphing into
this power game the u.s. the US Open in
the USGA is here to remind us that
accuracy is just as important power and
in golf and where does it rank because
I've got Costner on the show tomorrow
the United States Open ranked with tin
cup Peter well the thing is that I won
the US Open in tin cup and I just had to
beat Costner and Don Johnson is probably
the proudest moment of my golf career
that ranks up there right there beating
Don Johnson and Costner yeah one of the
greatest greatest lines in the movie my
kids loved it when I laid it up on the
72nd hole the open God's return to teach
and said Dickinson's laying up my kids
thought that was the greatest thing in
the world he says Kevin Cosby just said
our name that would be my ringtone
you know like make that my ringtone on
my phone any time it rings it were just
Jacobson's laying up but fantastic
that's a great idea I'm just ready to
get that done who was the best at
celebrity golfer you ever played with
obviously you won the the pro-am on
Pebble who's the best one you've ever
teed it up with Peter best celebrity
golfer I ever played with his Danny age
you get to play for obviously the
Celtics the Blazer is now easy p.m. with
the Celtics I played a lot of golf with
Danny Danny then you won point it if he
wanted to go a different direction and
play golf he could have he doesn't play
professionally don't know if I could
have got his card he would have been
very close all right and then if you
don't mind who who's on the opposite end
of the spectrum a celebrity a golfer
player that you're like oh gosh Charles
is real good on the practice range I do
the NBC broadcast at the American
Century
Brice celebrity Tahoe over here and I
love to talk to Charles he really good
on the range ranch but but he gets on
the golf course he's not he's not able
to take it from the range to the course
for some reason it's the it's between
the temples isn't it Peter it's
definitely there it's right upstairs and
but nobody has more fun than Charles
Barkley you know what obviously teeing
off with him would be for so many people
a dream come true all right before
before I let you go who are you hanging
with for the US Open this time around
what do you got going on well I'm well
I'm here at the Lexus performance tent
lectures got over 300 automobiles
running around the 17 mile drive
providing courtesy transportation I'm
just kind of hanging with my crew just a
lot of friends and family here but the
guy I'm laying money on this week I'm
gonna go with Dustin Dustin Johnson my
god Dustin Johnson so is that just
because it's it's his time and kept the
odds of him doing it three straight time
so our interview started with you saying
it's been a hundred years since we've
seen somebody do that is that is that
essentially what I'm walking to her yeah
I I think you're right what's cool about
the US Open is it goes from
a golf course two different course this
year world back to New York Wingfoot
this here at Pebble Beach so it really
takes something special somebody special
and and Kathy is a very special player
but to win three in a row there's a
reason why it hasn't been done since
1905 it's hard to do Peter you're the
man thanks for joining
enjoy the time I'd love to have you on
any other time as well and certainly if
you're here in Los Angeles right here in
studio I'd love it great work you too
thanks that's a Peter Jacobsen at Jake
trout on Twitter and Peter Jacobson golf
on Instagram here on the Rich Eisen show
from the US Open for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app